missouri misery a
school district revives paddling to
disciplined students misery school
district i like my mom my mom right now
is like yeah there must be a lot of
middle easterners
a school district in southwest missouri
is bringing back a measure it last
resorted to over two decades ago to
address disciplinary moments a problem
spanking students classed classes
started monday for 1900 students and
in cassville
uh school district about an hour west of
branson and some 15 miles from the
arkansas border during open house
families were notified that the school
board had adopted a policy in june
allowing use of physical force as a
method of correcting student behavior
parents were handed forms to specify
what oh my
this is washington post story this is
known as
child
formerly known as corporal punishment
the disciplinary measure you usually
involve striking students on the
buttocks
with a wooden paddle a teacher or
principal must send a report to the
superintendent explaining the reasoning
behind the punishment i'll bet you
anything those kids are going to get
better grades they're not going to skip
school and their future like do a
percentage of how good those kids are
going to be in college and those kids
are going to be amazing bro because
that's what's like to me society has
gone down the tubes
by the way if you're watching this if
you're watching him do a poll
already okay i want to see what the look
is if you look at the cartoon if you're
if you're if you're like this is a good
idea give a thumbs up if you say this is
a terrible idea give a thumbs down i'm
actually curious okay so by the way as a
parent what do you think about this
giving the green light a little spanky
spank
what do you think uh you know what
i'm cool with it within within certain
standards i'm cool with it you're cool
with it because no one's gonna spank
your daughters okay because they're good
kids i'm concerned because yeah
give a hypothetical
bailey acts up in class one day and the
teacher hits her bailey is 16. i think
you need to dive into this and see that
okay okay so bro second grade or under
okay so when they were kids let's not
when if when brooke was
seven years old 10 years old you'd be
okay with the teacher hitting them no no
no no this is
this is like
five six year old what have you read
okay go to it let's see what is that but
the point is would you be okay with it
if they were younger within standards
yeah right you'd be okay with the
teacher hitting your kids wow not me
sure it's not hitting the kid they find
it different they're invoking spanking
spanking is a spank on your butt dude
that that's what that's what's wrong
with society is because nobody gets
spanked anymore i don't know
listen i'm old enough to remember i
remember i was in i think second grade
at the time i remember teachers would
pull your ears yes and bring you up to
the front of the classroom by your
earlobe
i'm like what the [ __ ] is happening
right now you're not my mom and teachers
would do that that's unheard of we had
in fifth grade they had a board of
education and they were on a board like
a paddle and yeah you know why we stayed
in line because we didn't want to get
hit i'm dead serious i did crazy [ __ ]
but i stayed in line because i know that
they hit me back that they've hit me and
then they call my mom and they're like
i've got trouble they'd call my mom my
my walk home she'd be in the balcony and
i had she had that middle eastern
look but pvd this is what dylan's age
shout out to you somebody just did a
super chat 20 bucks
user's name is big daddy brown nine okay
big daddy brown nine gave 20 bucks
incredible for this 20 bucks and he says
the only person who gets to paddle me is
adam
[Laughter]
nice shout out done for 20 bucks
20 minutes
no but like listen i i for us it was a
ruler between your fingers and they
squeezing wow
what does that mean ruler between your
fingers and they squeeze it like this
okay and then it was take your shoes off
and socks off and lift one of your feet
up they would hold it and they would hit
it with a ruler on the bottom of the
this is in iran this is any robber okay
i mean this is a whole let's go to
america here for a second yeah well hold
on i'm surprised they didn't like you
know
but that's what it was and you and i'm
actually not joking with you that's what
it was in iran okay so and look how you
turned out i'm actually shocked it
wasn't way worse when i grew up i had
friends that went to catholic school and
they used to talk about the nuns with
the forearms and a tattoo of an anchor
yeah you know like popeye yeah i was
like man sister mary watch out yeah
she's crazy she's she's like she's
tattered and buff sister
you know it's
it's like i was failing penmanship of
course
we just had our friend the priest on
recently so i mean these people are they
go without uh
getting their rocks off so this is like
you know s m for them these uh sisters
and boy fathers don't go there
you think i'm going there they went the
church went there buddy the church don't
they defend the church guys the church
they went there i can't comment on the
church
who's there
what are you big tech tom he's
restricting my freedom by the way alex
patino just said
wow
while growing up in mexico during the
90s my teachers used to hit us with big
wooden rulers not only being pulled by
ear also but by the hair and grown
beside your ear or fist
close hit on the head wow and i bet you
he has a great job he's a good person
he's a good person he's a good person
and pays his taxes
every every grandpa right now that tells
the story of the wooden paddle with the
holes in it the tape wrapped around the
handle is going utilized
you're gonna get they're complaining
about the the generation how bad the
youth are they're going you're gonna get
a senior are
if a kid gets hit in school they'll turn
out to be a better kid i think and this
is my opinion again
the generation that i was in and i think
up to one or two after mine we got
disciplined we didn't get i hate when
people still be i never got beaten i got
hit and i heard those words wait until
your father comes home that [ __ ]
instilled fear and we knew stay in
certain line yeah
i went a little bit to the right i went
a little bit left but knowing that
there's a consequence for your action
that's why everything's so [ __ ] up
right now sorry for my french because
now like when you back in the day when
your parent was like don't touch this
and you kind of went close like ah you
know not to do it now kids are like what
are you gonna do call the [ __ ] cup i
own you because you can't even touch me
now they send you to the principal and
they suspend you for three days and the
kid's going awesome yeah i don't have to
go to school yeah exactly that so when
you knew pat like when your dad was
gonna hit you you didn't do it i mean
you you skirted around it there's no
discipline now there's no you can't even
talk to them because their feelings are
protected more than anything you know
there was a part of this that used to be
in in boot camp in the military that
they used to do is they got away with it
because it was abuse you know there
there was this also in military a lot
they have you're also 18 20 years old
and gradually they went away saying this
isn't healthy
uh you know i don't know i i i don't
know if
there's many ways to discipline your
kids many ways to discipline people many
ways to punish them
uh many ways so then the argument that
me comes if you're okay with this are
you also okay with the death penalty
like how do you feel about the death
penalty
i'm okay with it and certainly
yes for example give me which certain
instances
insider trading
[Music]
nancy pelosi nancy pelosi and her
husband what like i was i told you
nicholas cruz so for instance any of
these mass murderer kids like the uvalde
guy parkland like
off with his [ __ ] head yeah i like
okay and potentially his family yeah oh
i remember we had that talking
so we're going back i went up there no
pat you know what i think i think if
you've killed an innocent person
or any of the time this is my opinion if
you've killed somebody and i love these
videos i think it should be implemented
if you've murdered one two i don't care
how many they put you like in that court
while you're handcuffed and the family
gets to have their way with you while
you're handcuffed for five minutes if
you live go to jail if you die you die
i'm i would [ __ ] pay-per-view that's
totally okay with these you know my
brother killed my mother uh we're gonna
beat your ass in court and if you die
that's it and we pay-per-view it
that's i'm actually okay with that
you're turning into a business model
which is interesting
that's his blue ocean strategy
so awesome stop
i'm okay with capital punishment you are
yep and i feel that the multi-level
appeal
in the u.s appellate courts and the
governor's stay
you know is very effective
when you execute an individual in most
u.s states
i think the number is
20
that there's been 20 not just a motion
in court but there's been like 20
different um items of appeal
and it's part of our system the are you
sure
and then ultimately if the governor
agrees remember the governor's got the
last thing does he give him a stay of
execution if the governor doesn't then
we've reached the point and we're done
with it
so i
i'm okay with it and i think the system
works now people are going to say that
before dna evidence
innocent men
were executed and we have now found that
absolutely be correct i'm talking about
today
with all that we have
um i'm okay with the death penalty in
the united states and the appellate
system and the governor's control
i'm okay with it so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
you